1994 was the year it all started
after numerous attempts at trying to
enter the video game market
including failed partnerships with both
nintendo and sega
sony decided to go it alone and released
their first console
the playstation launching in japan on
december 3rd with cd-rom technology that
allowed for the most
impressive 3d graphics of the time the
playstation got off to a strong start in
japan
with its sales bolstered by huge
releases such as ridge racer
the playstation wouldn't hit north
america until 1995.
at e3 that summer sega revealed that its
sega saturn would launch for 399
and would be released months ahead of
schedule straight after sony took to the
stage to reveal the playstation price
and well see for yourself
[Applause]
launching with titles such as rayman and
ridge racer with wipeout following
closely behind
the original playstation sold 2.2
million units in just over a year
and became the first console to sell
over a hundred million units
which it did so in just under a decade
sony also launched the playstation link
cable just in time for christmas 1995
so that players could connect their
consoles and play co-op or multiplayer
games
on two separate tvs the playstation was
selling
gangbusters and 1996 was packed full of
critically acclaimed third-party games
franchises like crash bandicoot and
resident evil were released
and became huge hits tomb raider was
such a smash hit on playstation
that sony quickly negotiated a deal with
core design
to make the series a playstation console
exclusive which it remained as
until 2000. in 1997 sony continued to
build its library of beloved games
grand theft auto and gran turismo
arrived along with sequels to crash and
tomb raider
as well as the world's most famous
rapping dog
sony also started making hardware
revisions with the playstation
controller getting an overhaul
two thumbsticks and rumble support were
added to the controller
and it was released with the name dual
analog controller
it was revised once more to add rubber
grips and change the handles and
shoulder buttons
they called it the dual shock and in
1998
one game would take advantage of the
dualshock's new vibration feature to
break the fourth wall
psychomantis would ask you to put your
controller down and make it vibrate
to demonstrate his psychokinesis
abilities
1999 saw the launch of a new peripheral
for the playstation
the pocket station inspired by the
dreamcast's visual memory unit
it was a memory card with a screen on it
and certain games like final fantasy
8 could transfer mini games onto the
pocket station for you to play on its
lcd screen
it was only ever released in japan but
demand for it globally wasn't high
everyone was too busy gearing up for
what the millennium would bring
the playstation 2 launched in 2000 and
it was
hugely successful in japan several
thousand people queued up in
akihabara to try and get their hands on
one on launch day
the console went on sale at midnight and
it was sold out by 10 am
not only was it backwards compatible
with playstation games and hardware
it was the first console to play dvds
despite its hardware not being the most
cutting edge
playstation had a huge fan base and many
franchises that people were eager to see
more instalments of
and they wouldn't have to wait long 2001
was a boon for playstation 2 owners
with new grand theft auto final fantasy
silent hill and metal gear solid games
as well as the debut of now acclaimed
titles like eco and devil may cry
sony also launched its online servers
for the ps2 in japan
allowing for multiplayer and co-op in
select titles
the service would launch in 2002 in
north america
and will be supported by a number of
titles socom would be one of the first
console games to support voice chat
sly cooper debuted on the ps2 that same
year as did ratchet and clank
developers sucker punch productions and
insomniac games would actually be
acquired
years later by sony to make games solely
for playstation
in 2003 sony released the i toy a camera
that would plug into the console and
allow players to play motion activated
mini games
or dance along to pop hits by the end of
the year it had sold almost 2.5 million
units in north america
and europe playstation's 4a into
peripherals didn't end there
in 2004 it released sing-star mics to
get us all karaoke from the comfort of
our own homes
the playstation portable also launched
in japan with ken kutaragi
one of the original engineers behind the
playstation calling it the walkman of
the 21st century
seeing how successful dvd support had
been for ps2
sony ensured that the psp was a
multimedia powerhouse too
it could play music movies and of course
games as well as surf the web
the psp launched worldwide in 2005 and
over the course of its lifespan
over 1300 games would be released for
the system
the ps2 meanwhile hit a huge milestone
that year
100 million units shipped doing so in
just over five years compared to the
playstation's 10.
prototypes of the ps3 were shown at e3
that year
along with games like metal gear solid 4
but the biggest takeaway was the
controller's very
distinct new look but the ps2 still had
some life in it yet with some incredible
and important games being released on it
in 2005
including the original god of war and
guitar hero which you may not know
started life as a ps2 exclusive
2006 was a year of saying goodbye to the
past
and hello to the future after hitting
100 million units sold on the original
playstation
sony ceased production on its first
console
at e3 that year all anyone could talk
about was the ps3
but for all the wrong reasons when first
announced it was
incredibly expensive with the 60
gigabyte model retailing
for 600 the console launched in north
america and japan
later that year but the rest of the
world had to wait until 2007.
the ps3 had a blu-ray drive and parts
for its production were in short supply
but the blu-ray support in the ps3
proved crucial in establishing blu-ray
discs as the new
dominant home media format rip hd dvds
the ps3's online functionality was far
greater than the ps2s
the playstation network served as an
online hub where players could add
friends and earn
trophies from completing in-game feats
the playstation store allowed players to
purchase and download games
straight from their console the
boomerang controller from e3 2005 was no
more
instead the six axis controller came
with the ps3
the wireless device could sense motion
but lacked the vibration from previous
consoles
due to an ongoing lawsuit with developer
immersion over the use of haptic
feedback in controllers
but it would be added back in in 2007
when sony and immersion decided to end
the ongoing legal battle
and the six axis was replaced with the
dualshock 3 in japan
with a worldwide release the following
year a follow-up to the itoy called the
playstation i was also released
allowing for more mixed reality gaming
it was bundled with a program called i
create which allowed users to capture
and edit their own video content
by filming it through the camera a
precursor to a lot of the share
functionality
that would come with the ps4 and v 2007
also marked the launch of one of sony's
biggest franchises
uncharted in 2008 playstation home
launched
marketed as a social environment that
was free to explore using an avatar
playstation home was a strange mix of
second life meets
gaming arcade users could create an
avatar
play games or watch movies with friends
or even do up their own apartments
big game releases that year included
metal gear solid 4
and little big planet sony launched an
updated model of the ps3 in 2009
the ps3 slim they also changed the
playstation logo
because of the close resemblance to
sony's spider-man movies
and a game called demon souls birthed a
major new genre of games
2010 was a big year for ps3 playstation
move motion controllers launched and
with them a slew of games like ipad
and singstar dance the playstation plus
online service also launched that summer
offering demos discounts on games and
cloud storage for saved files
as well as two free games every month
unfortunately being able to play
multiplayer games online
also fell under the subscription model
but that wouldn't be the worst thing to
happen to psn
that would come in 2011 with the
playstation network hack
over 77 million psn accounts were
compromised
and while the issue was being dealt with
sony took the entire psn
service down for around three weeks sony
offered two free games per system
and 30 days of free ps plus to its users
as an apology
the company estimated that the hack cost
them 171
million dollars at the end of 2011 sony
launched the ps vita in japan
which made its way to the rest of the
world in 2012.
designed by takashi sagabe the designer
of the original walkman
the vita had an oled touchscreen and six
axis motion system
as well as a touchpad on the back of the
console instead of umd discs like the
psp supported
games came on cards or could be
downloaded from the playstation store
games like persona 4 golden uncharted
golden abyss
and gravity rush all found their home on
sony's new portable system
while titles such as the indie game
journey dominated the conversation on
ps3 that year
in 2013 naughty dog released one of
playstation's most
defining games the last of us praised
for its mature and heartfelt
storytelling as well as gameplay and
visuals
naughty dog had cemented itself as one
of the best first party developers in
the playstation stable
and gave the ps3 its swan song title it
released a next-gen version of the last
of us
just a year later in early 2013 sony
held a playstation meeting in new york
where system architect mark cerny gave a
detailed breakdown of the playstation 4
hardware
and the new dualshock 4 controller was
revealed most impressive was that games
could be suspended
the new console put into rest mode and
then the game could be resumed with a
button press
digital games could also be played while
they were downloading
gaikai a cloud gaming service that sony
had bought a year prior
also made an appearance with the news
that psn would be integrated with the
system
remote play would also be possible on
the ps vita
multimedia features were expanded upon
sharing screenshots and video clips was
now easier than ever
and the ps4 home screen now offered a
feed to see what your friends were up to
at e3 that year the console design was
revealed along with the 400
price tag and games which would be
coming to the console
like infamous second sun and the order
1886. within 24 hours of the console's
launch that november
1 million units were sold in north
america the ps4 had been criticized for
its lack of backwards compatibility so
in 2014
playstation now launched leveraging
gaikai technology the subscription
service allowed users to play
ps3 and ps4 games via the cloud on their
consoles
or via their pc in 2015 playstation held
one of their greatest e3 showcases
ever with huge titles such as uncharted
4 horizon zero dawn and
shenmue 3. it also re-announced the last
guardian which many had feared cancelled
and unveiled final fantasy 7 remake also
that year one of the console's best
exclusives would launch
bloodborne 2016 saw a bunch of hardware
revisions for the playstation ecosystem
the launch model began to be phased out
replaced by the ps4 slim
a more powerful version of the console
the ps4 pro
which came with more internal storage
and could upscale footage to 4k
was also released not done with
peripherals sony made a foray into vr
with the psvr headset
making vr more affordable and accessible
to millions
who already owned a ps4 console 2017 was
a relatively uneventful year
but critically acclaimed titles like
horizon zero dawn and persona 5
bolstered the playstation 4 catalogue
meanwhile the playstation 3 was finally
discontinued in japan
classic playstation franchises found new
homes on ps4 in 2018.
god of war launched in april and was
praised for both its gameplay and more
mature
nuanced storytelling bluepoint games
remade the ps2 classic shadow of the
colossus
to bring it to an entirely new audience
on playstation 4.
sony finally reversed its stern
cross-platform play policy
allowing fortnite players to game with
friends on other platforms
in 2019 sony didn't attend e3
making it the first that it had ever
missed in the show's 24 year history
opting instead to release videos online
called state of play
which were modeled after nintendo's
directs sony made other big moves that
year
acquiring spider-man and ratchet and
clank developer insomniac games for 229
million dollars
by december 2019 the ps4 had sold 100
million units
which brings us to 2020. the ps5 was
officially unveiled at the future
of gaming event in june at launch
there'll be two models one with a disk
drive and one digital only
in terms of technological improvements
the ps5 plays games in native 4k and
features a solid state drive
that decreases load time significantly
the console also supports ray tracing
3d audio and backwards compatibility
with 99
of ps4 games a new controller the dual
sense
contains a microphone haptic feedback in
its triggers
and a dedicated create button to take
screenshots and share clips with your
friends
playstation 5's ui has had a major
overhaul adding activity cards that
allow you to jump into specific parts of
a game you're playing
track trophies and even get walkthroughs
picture in picture
as you're playing launch titles include
spiderman miles morales
sackboy a big adventure and demon souls
remade
by bluepoint 25 years and a whole lot of
history
there's still more to come in
playstation story and we'll always have
the latest
thanks for watching keep your eyes
peeled to gamespot
[Music]
you